Zombies have been an essential presence in
film ever since "Night of the Living Dead"
released in 1968, but they've found serious
mainstream appeal in the past several decades.
Here are some 21st century masterpieces that
fans of all things undead can't afford to miss.
Before he got his handful of Oscars for "Slumdog
Millionaire," British director Danny Boyle grabbed
audiences' attention with 2002's "28 Days Later,"
which stars Cillian Murphy as a man who awakens
from a coma and finds himself in an abandoned
London. Both the protagonist and the audience
are thrust right into a world turned upside down,
one that's full of violent monsters that have been
infected with the aptly named Rage Virus. Even
more frightening than the relentless zombies,
however, are the greedy humans who find
themselves going mad with their newfound power.
Although Boyle would go on to direct slow-burning
dramas based on real life like "127 Hours" and
"Steve Jobs," "28 Days Later" showed off his
ability to direct grisly horror at breakneck
speed. Grimy yet intimate cinematography and
emotional supporting performances from Naomie
Harris and Brendan Gleeson make for an experience
that's as raw as the meat that zombies love to
consume. Even considering all of the other
impressive movies Boyle has helmed in the
decades since its release, "28 Days Later"
still remains one of his finest creations,
as well as an essential and influential film
in the 21st-century canon of zombie cinema.
"Shaun of the Dead" may not be the first
film to lovingly parody zombie cinema,
but it's certainly one of the funniest. Edgar
Wright's second feature film was his first to
feature the dynamic duo of Simon Pegg and Nick
Frost, a combination that has proven its worth
time and time again with projects like the
movie "Hot Fuzz" and the TV show "Spaced."
This hilarious story about the last people to
learn about the zombie apocalypse showcases
Wright's British sense of humor, impeccable
comedic timing, and trademark energy behind
the camera. Filled with quotable lines and
recurring gags, the banter between Shaun and
his friends is a breath of fresh air in a genre
so often filled with nothing but doom and gloom.
"What's the matter, David?
Not taken a shortcut before?"
Charming critics and audiences alike,
"Shaun of the Dead" proved itself to be
a 21st century comedy classic. Not only did
it kick off the iconic "Cornetto Trilogy"
that continued with "Hot Fuzz" and "The
World's End," but it also established
Wright as a filmmaker to watch and set a
new standard for not just zombie comedies,
but for comedies in general. Not
too shabby for a rookie director.
In the wake of "Twilight" making serious cash
at the box office, it was only a matter of
time before more human-monster romances made
their way to the silver screen. One of these
films was 2013's "Warm Bodies," which swapped
out sparkling vampires for shambling zombies.
However, viewers expecting just another
"Twilight" knock-off were in for a surprise,
as director Jonathan Levine managed to imbue
the film with more heart and soul than anyone
expected a movie about reanimated corpses to have.
Rather than delivering what might be considered
"realistic" visions of how the infected might
look and act, "Warm Bodies" revels in the
awkward oddity of classic zombies — the ones
that eat brains, move slow, and can barely
speak. This makes for plenty of fun comedy
and some unexpectedly heartfelt moments when
a walking corpse falls head over rotting heels
for a human woman after defending her
from several of his undead compatriots.
Totally committed lead performances from Nicholas
Hoult and Teresa Palmer help deliver a movie
romance that's more than a little off the beaten
path; a relationship that you can't help but root
for. This Romeo and Juliet story is filled with
heart, whether that heart is beating or not.
In the late 2000s, nearly a decade
after "The Blair Witch Project"
brought found-footage into the mainstream,
the genre saw a major resurgence with films
like the low-budget supernatural thriller
"Paranormal Activity" and the mysterious
kaiju feature "Cloverfield." This trend
wasn't limited just to America, though,
as Spain delivered its own unique spin on the
zombie genre with the incredibly freaky "REC."
The film follows a reporter who accompanies
a group of firemen to an emergency at an
apartment building where a zombie outbreak
has recently begun, only to find themselves
locked inside by the authorities with nowhere to
escape. Directors Jaume Balagueró and Paco Plaza
use the found footage format not just as a way to
keep production costs down, but rather as a way to
immerse audiences in a world of frightening
uncertainty. The brazenly chilling imagery
throughout "REC" ensured that it couldn't be
mistaken for any other zombie flick at the time,
embedding itself in viewers'
minds like an axe to the head.
The box office success of "REC" spawned not
only a sequel, but an American remake in the
form of the 2008 motion picture "Quarantine,"
However, "Quarantine" impressed far fewer
critics than the first Spanish film, and more
than a decade later, it's still the original
"REC" that's keeping moviegoers up at night with
its bold approach to found-footage filmmaking.
It's easy to imagine a version of "Zombieland"
that's just an American remake of "Shaun of
the Dead," but this 2009 comedy feature
was able to establish its own identity
on the backs of its many iconic performances.
Jesse Eisenberg's neurotic everyman,
Woody Harrelson's thrill-seeking
badass, and Emma Stone and Abigail
Breslin's wisecracking con artist sisters
make up an eccentric zombie survival squad
that's as good at busting guts as they
are at busting hordes of the undead.
Director Ruben Fleischer gives "Zombieland" plenty
of unique flourishes that make it stand out in the
increasingly crowded world of zombie cinema. These
include memorable rules for survival, a colorful
climax in an amusement park, and of course, an
unforgettable cameo from Bill Murray as himself.
"So do you have any regrets?"
"...Garfield, maybe."
With this many laughs, it's no wonder
that "Zombieland" cultivated a fanbase
so devoted that it got a sequel an entire
decade after its release in "Zombieland:
Double Tap." Much like the walking
dead, "Zombieland" refuses to die,
and it's not hard to see why: comedies this
good are rarer than a Twinkie in the apocalypse.
Looking for a zombie movie to watch with
the whole family? The options may be scarce,
but "ParaNorman" proves they're out
there. The second film from Laika Studios,
"ParaNorman" is the offbeat story of Norman, a
kid who can see ghosts, and follows his quest
to save his small town from Puritan zombies and a
witch's curse. The project may not be as intense
as your typical zombie flick, but it shouldn't
surprise anyone familiar with Laika's infamously
creepy first feature, "Coraline," that there's no
shortage of scares here, regardless of age rating.
The zombies and ghosts in "ParaNorman"
aren't just here for the frights, though;
they help tell a delightful story about
friendship, acceptance, and what makes all
of us unique. Each frame is lovingly crafted
with Laika's impressive stop-motion animation,
which lends a signature tactile quality to
everything from a zombie's dangling jaw to a
smear of nail polish. "ParaNorman" is a film
that's equal parts chilling and thoughtful,
and its overwhelming heart has made it one of
the more critically acclaimed animated movies
of the 21st century. This insightful take
on the genre is perfect for horror-loving
parents who want to get their children
in on the action from a young age.
Zombie movies have been used as a means for
providing social commentary since "Night of
the Living Dead," a trend that continued into
2020 with Jeff Barnaby's "Blood Quantum."
In this film, as the zombie apocalypse spreads
across North America, the native residents of
a First Nations reserve find themselves strangely
immune from the infection. Unfortunately for them,
there's no such thing as immunity from getting
torn to shreds, so three generations must work
together to navigate the new undead status quo
and save as many people as they possibly can.
Throughout its runtime, "Blood Quantum" offers
ruminations on experiences specific to indigenous
individuals, who rarely find themselves in
heroic leading roles in mainstream film.
Excellent performances by indigenous
actors Michael Greyeyes, Forrest Goodluck,
and Stonehorse Lone Goeman make for an
undeniably harrowing viewing experience.
Despite a rocky release and mixed public
reception, "Blood Quantum" received
overwhelmingly positive marks from critics,
with Roxana Hadadi from Pajiba praising,
"[It] takes aim at colonization and the
subjugation of native and indigenous peoples,
and [Barnaby is] wrapping those
considerations in writhing coils
of intestines and splattering them
with a hot burst of arterial blood."
The combination of social
commentary and blood-soaked carnage
makes "Blood Quantum" more than
just an entertaining thrill ride.
It's also an exciting expansion on the kind
of themes that zombie movies can explore.
"One Cut of the Dead" is, in a word, ingenious.
This Japanese zombie comedy revels in its twists
and turns, but even without spoiling
its big surprises, it's easy to say
that director Shin'ichirō Ueda displays a level
of creativity never before seen in this genre.
When a crew making a low-budget zombie flick
is attacked by actual, real-life zombies,
their unhinged director demands that they keep
the camera rolling for maximum authenticity,
putting everyone around him in mortal danger
in order to get that one perfect shot.
As actors and crew members fight for
their lives, the camera shows the
action in a single extended take,
capturing the chaos in real time.
Ueda does impressive work handling the shift from
a casual hangout vibe to all hell breaking loose,
all without ever taking a single break in
the action. Keep watching after the credits,
though, because nothing in this movie is quite
what it seems. At once a rollercoaster ride
and an exercise in unearthing depth
in even the most unexpected places,
the sense of creativity in "One Cut
of the Dead" is very much alive!
A Christmas zombie musical might sound like a
mismatched mess, but "Anna and the Apocalypse"
not only proves that it can be done, but
that it can be done well. This yuletide tale,
following Anna and her high school friends as
they try to navigate a sudden zombie apocalypse,
works precisely because it leans completely
into everything that makes it unique,
transporting audiences into a campy
world full of festive frights.
Just because this is a musical doesn't mean the
zombies are any less menacing, though; "Anna and
the Apocalypse" doesn't skimp on the blood and
gore, especially when Anna's signature candy cane
weapon is involved. The musical numbers aren't
lacking, either; tunes like "Hollywood Ending"
and "Soldier at War" are sure to stay stuck
in your head even long after the credits roll.
"Anna and the Apocalypse" isn't smashing
together genres to make some belabored punchline;
its affection for every type of storytelling
it lampoons is both evident and endearing.
Like so many culinary treats, "Anna and the
Apocalypse" is what happens when you get
something magical out of fusing together
things that aren't typically paired up.
"Zombies on a train" might sound as silly an
idea as "Snakes on a Plane," but that's the
central conceit behind "Train to Busan," one
of the greatest zombie movies not just of the
21st century, but of all time. Writer
Park Joo-suk and director Yeon Sang-ho
trap a packed cast of characters into the
cramped confines of a train that suddenly
becomes infested with hordes of the undead. The
passengers must move beyond barriers of class and
age and work as a team in order to survive their
perilous journey to the coastal city of Busan.
While "Train to Busan" will certainly give
any zombie lover their fill of undead carnage,
it's the humanity of its living protagonists
that truly makes it shine. The characters
in "Train to Busan" are memorable and lovable —
especially Ma Dong-seok's character Yoon Sang-hwa,
a charismatic tough guy with a heart
of gold who takes down zombies with his
fists. With such engaging figures to ground
the story, "Train to Busan" makes audiences
cry rather than cheer when its characters
meet their untimely ends. Who knew the
key to creating a flawless zombie movie was
simply putting them on public transportation?
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.